[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and thank you for
being with me until the end of the line
the final episode of falcon in the
winter soldier is here and throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the easter eggs
things you missed and giving our review
of the entire series
we're also going to be talking about
what could be coming next in the mcu
so make sure you stick around until the
end both spoilers ahead so if you don't
want anything ruined then i recommend
that you turn off now
huge thank you for getting last week's
video trending and please click the
thumbs up for the final time if you've
enjoyed the coverage
without the way you're the best now
let's get into falcon in the winter
soldier
okay so last time we picked up with john
walker texas ranger
and the aftermath of murdering a flag
smasher the death of his best friend
battlestar had pushed him to the brink
and thus sam and bucky decided to do
what most people would do
which is take him somewhere quiet and
kick the crap out of him
walker was stripped of the mantle
however he was contacted by valentina
allegra de la fontaine
who we now know will also be featuring
in the upcoming movie black widow
walker visited battle star's family and
even though the episode was called the
truth
he lied to them and told them that the
perpetrator responsible for his death
had been brought to justice this is
something that's important to remember
for this entry
hence why i'm mentioning it up top
elsewhere sam decided to become captain
america
and with his wings left behind it looks
like joaquin torres
is waiting in the wings to pick up the
pieces hey we ended with the flag
smashes storming the grc as they voted
on the patch act
and i can't believe that i missed last
time that this is the bench which sam
jackson and bruce willis
opened their own suitcase at in die hard
with a vengeance
the episode culminated with cosplay cap
making a brand new shield
and falcon opening up a suitcase much
like pulp fiction
with wha what is that is that what oh
sorry wrong show
now episode six is called one world one
people the mantra of the flag smashes
however it's also a song by femi cootie
in it he puts across the point that
black people
nigerians especially have been held back
by corrupt governments and politicians
but that there is still hope that people
will rise up against these forces
it offers a shining light in these dark
times which is something that i think
sam definitely becomes in this entry we
open with the flag smashers forming
their attack
while sam and bucky head towards the drc
along the way
sharon appears in disguise doing the
same high-tech facial prosthetics that
black widow did in the winter soldier
this speaks to her two-phase persona
throughout the series and the eventual
reveal that comes in the middle of the
episode
turns out that the flag smashers were
waiting for sam's arrival
and they gassed the vote meeting before
he swoops in donning the wakunden wings
suit and shield this feels like it was
ripped straight out of the sam wilson
captain america run
and it's an amazing looking costume that
feels so good getting introduced in this
hero moment
he tells people he's captain america and
we get a repeat of the hilarious
conspiracy theory from episode 1
which says that captain america is on
the moon now whilst i thought this was
mental
judging by some of the reveals that come
later on maybe it's true
now before we can appreciate it batrock
arrives and the pair face off in a
moment that echoes the opening of the
winter soldier
turns out carly wants the grc to
evacuate rather than remaining inside
and she actually tries to bargain with
bucky at one point
bucky mentions that he's fought for
something bigger than himself and failed
twice
which i'm guessing might be civil war
and infinity war
but let me know below if you disagree he
tells carly to do one
and we realized that she was simply
buying time to enact her own plans
in the car park he steals a bike and
sharon sticks an explosive made of
mercury vapour on a flag smasher named
lennox
you know for someone who seems like they
want super soldiers so they can protect
them back home
definitely doesn't seem that way now
throughout this season one of my big
criticisms has been
that most of sam's fights have been on
the ground outside of the first episode
he's been down to earth in order to
allow bucky to do things
but having him get to take to the skies
to chase a helicopter is absolutely
incredible
i love how he throws the shield to smash
a window and then jumps out in order to
catch it
he also uses red wing to scan for a
pilot and even his wings as cover later
on
with this happening publicly it allows
the world to see firsthand that he
deserves the mantle
and hearing people cheer in this moment
was a really nice touch
now the following action scene in the
street has many call backs to other
works
firstly the fight between bucky and the
flag smasher is a reflection of the one
that he had with steve at the midpoint
of the winter soldier
several of the moves are repeated here
and in addition to this
john walker arrives this massively
echoes when the character showed up in
sam wilson captain america
and he fought sam in the middle of the
street in the comics he was u.s agent at
this point
and he was there to publicly humiliate
sam so that people would lose faith in
him
now whilst that isn't really the case
here walker is trying to make it so that
people believe he's still captain
america
but when his diy shield gets kicked out
of the way
it goes down worse than demi lovato at
the big chill frozen yogurt shop
yikes now because it's not made of
vibranium it's nowhere near as effective
and the character gets triggered when
carly says that lamar's life didn't
matter
well it mad to me now throughout the
last episode
we watched as walker was haunted by
visions of him
shouts to ryan arie at screen thrush for
pointing out that walker would talk out
loud to his parents in the comics
even though they were gone in the source
material them getting murdered was what
drove him to be crazy
and though they changed it up to lamar
and this i do appreciate the callback
sam hits up a woman to ride his chopper
but instead of laying the pipe the pipe
lays him
we really need some better writers here
now it might be a reach but this moment
reminded me of tony escaping his
destroyed home in iron man 3
and it shows just how well equipped sam
now is he's pretty much a combination of
both
iron man and captain america at this
point and could easily fill the void
that the pair have left after end game
sam's plan of swapping the pilot out
works and the battle with the flag
smashes continues with carly trying to
crash the truck containing the grc into
a construction site
the music echoes the ending of civil war
and when all hope seems lost
sam comes in and saves the day an
onlooker calls him the black falcon
which is of course what he was referred
to when he went to visit isaiah
however this is corrected to captain
america showing that the public now
believe he has the persona
the flag smashes flee to the basement of
the site and carly runs into sharon
here we learn it was sharon carter all
along
who was the power broker and it was the
the most obvious thing
and i'm not really sure how i feel about
it in all honesty
firstly there are a lot of
contradictions in it and we know from
zemo that he knew the character before
the events of civil war
he also called the power broker a he and
sharon was agent 13 at this point
and wasn't exiled so it doesn't really
line up
she's also had numerous points in the
series where she could have killed carly
but for some reason didn't now as for
sharon carter
she's someone who's comic roots i
haven't really touched upon but she's
got a great history i think we should go
over
so we can see how it lines up with the
show version born in virginia to parents
harrison and amanda carter
sharon was the niece to margaret aka
peggy
peggy suffered shell shock in the war
and was nursed back to help by the
family
and sharon would sit at her bedside
while she recounted stories from her
life
this inspired sharon to become an agent
of shield and after gaining the moniker
of agent 13
she was sent on several missions it
seemed that sharon picked up a lot of
her aunt's talents
and she quickly became one of the
company's best agents
interestingly in the comics sharon and
batrock actually went head-to-head on a
mission at one point
which too involved steve steve
recognized the resemblance to peggy but
didn't put two and two together
until much later down the line when he
was a bit
uh he might be crossing the line here a
bit now over the years they crossed
paths and became lovers
carter eventually joined the femme force
which was led by valentina
who has of course appeared in the series
carter spent some years in retirement
with steve
but she was called back to judy and
shield faked to death
when she was dropped behind enemy lines
however the agency believed that she had
been killed
i think it was a clerical error and she
was abandoned which led to her working
with several villains
i think this is meant to mirror her
being on the run for breaking the
sokovia accords
and because of this sharon grew a lot of
hate towards shield
she even became an agent of the red
skull and it definitely reflects her
journey throughout madrapue
she was wanted for treason but after
some time travel shenanigans to world
war ii
she managed to make things right by
speaking with nick fury
in the present she became a shield agent
once more and helped to head up the
investigation against the winter soldier
over the years she's had a very
interesting story and was even a cog in
the death of captain america
delivering one of the killing blows to
him she was brainwashed to be fair
which is something that they do a lot in
comic books for me i think the twist was
staring us in the face so much that i
actually ruled it out and i will take
the l for this but i think when we go
back and watch the mcu that it won't
quite line up
she put herself in harm's way at several
points and also let sam bucky and zemo
go and interrogate her golden goose
her plan was to help the flag smashes
and make them come back to her
but also not help them and yeah weird it
might just be being salty because i'm
taking the l
but either way that's the reveal and at
least i didn't ride the the zola train
like some of you
suckers you suck i'm just kidding i love
you
now sharon kills batroc and sam and
carly go head to head
whilst bucky and walker use the flag
smasher app to discover the location of
those escaping
sam faces his first one-on-one battle
against the super soldier
and initially he refuses to fight back
sharon ends up shooting carly and we see
her grip the hamza
a symbol that she's carried throughout
this means protection from the evil eye
and as the power broker has appeared as
eyes throughout the season
it's a nice symbolic gesture sam sweeps
in with her body in a moment that plays
upon the painting of kane and abel
something that too was echoed in arkham
city his enemy has fallen
but clearly sam feels regret over it and
he makes sure that the flag smashers
aren't referred to as terrorists all
labels do is stop people from
emphasizing
and sam says that they all have one
unified struggle now that they can unite
under
the grc have erased half of the planet
much in the same way that thanos did
and because of this the world is still
divided this plays out to the public
much in the same way that sam's uprising
in his comic run did
this is watched by isaiah as well as his
grandson eli
who in the comics becomes a hero known
as patriot
sam's speech shows isaiah that perhaps
the world has changed
and the character finally breathes a
sigh of relief it's a very inspiring
speech of him speaking to the world
leaders who could make changes
but refuse to and though it is very very
heavy-handed
its hearts in the right place it's
clearly discussing how people who make
the decisions are rarely affected by
them
and thus it's easy to cast people to the
side this was the moment i felt the
character really became captain america
and sure the action scenes were cool but
it's the beliefs and morals that really
make him who he is
walker even gives him a nod of approval
and bucky calls him cap
with everyone who knows sharon is the
power broker dead she's able to go back
into american society
and sam takes to the skies in order to
help out we see the flag smashers being
transported to the raft
but they're destroyed by zemo's butler
fully carrying out his plan
at the prison zemo overhears this on the
radio and we see him in a cell from
civil war
cut to valentina and olivia as we watch
us
agent being unveiled val so sorry i
shouldn't call her that
says things are gonna get weird and that
they're not gonna need captain america
for that
they're gonna need a u.s agent this is
clearly hinting towards her setting up
the thunderbolts
and the fact that walker will be used
more as law enforcement
rather than someone who stands for
beliefs and values walker's just happy
to be back
but whether he's learned the lessons he
should have or not remains to be seen
i really thought that the whole thing
with battlestar's family was gonna go
somewhere
but it doesn't which is a shame as it
seemed like they were setting it up but
it's just left on the cutting room floor
i might be reaching here but i very much
saw john walker lying about killing the
flag smasher as a comment on the iraq
war
now what i mean by that and stop shaking
your head is that we were originally
told there were wmds in the country
but over time this narrative proved to
be false and it changed to us being that
we were simply removing a vicious
dictator
the justification for the action changed
and we instantly knew that this guy
wasn't behind battlestar's death
but he was still killed and then put
forth as the reason for why walker acted
the way that he did
clearly this didn't sit right with some
people aka lamar's sister
whether this was included and then
forgotten about is a metaphor for that
we don't know
but yeah very strange to have it even
teased at
back home bucky goes to mr nakajima and
a repeat of the scene from the first
episode very much plays out
but this time bucky goes inside it's
absolutely beautiful
and so well acted and even though i'm
the hardest youtuber about
i might have i might have teared up a
bit over this now as sam said in episode
5
bucky wasn't making amends he was just
avenging
he needed to provide a service closure
to people who didn't have it
and this is very much what happens in
this moment bucky finally puts the lid
on the winter soldier
and he leaves a gift for his therapist
which contains the book of names
showing that he won't need it anymore
sam then visits isaiah and we learn that
the glc have stood down when it comes to
the patch act
sam knows what he's got to do and he
takes isaiah to the smithsonian which is
where that we see that a monument to him
has been added
this was a highly emotional moment and
showed that he hadn't been forgotten
about
actually got a lot of flashes of doctor
who here namely the scene in which doc
took vincent van gogh to visit an
exhibit for his artwork
back home sam and the community come
together for a party
on the docks beside the boat a huge
shout out to kevin smith and mark
bernardin at the fatman beyond podcast
for pointing out that the boat is very
much a metaphor for the shield
just bear with me now initially the boat
was something that he and his family
wrestled with getting rid of
they thought that it was their
responsibility but they didn't really
want it
however in the end they ended up calling
the community together in order to fix
it up
this represents how the shield has had a
lot of people that have helped to build
the legacy of it
the shield has a long and very
complicated one but sam tried with both
the boat and shield to take the rotten
things out of it
and make something new it's their own
ship of theseus in many ways
and it's also mephisto and mark
bernardin stated that we know the shield
and boat aren't perfect
but that if we come together and work
towards fixing it
it can stand for a symbol of greatness
again heck they even wanted to rename
the boat but in the end decided that it
was part of their history
and thus went against it i love this
idea and it's something that i missed
last time
so i just thought that i'd bring it up
here the show ends with the title screen
captain america and the winter soldier
and we cut to the post credits scene to
see sharon getting a pardon
now shout out to juan shironas for
messaging me on twitter to say that this
will likely lead into armor wars
as it seems like sharon will now have
access to everything
this includes the stark iron man tech
which could lead to her creating lots of
duplicates
now she clearly has another person
involved with her on the other end of
the phone
in the comics power broker inc was
actually made up of two people
and it is possible that the person on
the other end is also part of it
now sometimes they put subtitles in
place so you can see who characters are
talking to
but here sadly that isn't the case if i
had to guess i would imagine that it was
either valentina or general ross
or perhaps someone even worse this would
allow for the power broker comments from
zemo to still remain in place
meaning that he could be a male and also
someone that he knew before civil war
either way i think they're definitely
setting up armor wars in the
thunderbolts and potentially even a
nomad series
which charles murphy has said is in
development with bucky
sharon infiltrating the government with
their own shadowy organization
is of course a mirror of the way that
hydra did it to shield and again
it's like poetry they rhyme it might
even be the case that madame hydra has
hired her
and after the events of ant-man they've
managed to replicate cross's pin
particles
and start up all over again this would
mean that hydra is back in full force if
i'm right
but let me know below if you disagree
now as for my thoughts on the series as
a whole
i know i've kind of gone back and forth
over it but i did
really really enjoyed in the end i
actually binged watched the entire thing
back to back through the week
and there was just so much in it that
yeah in hindsight it works really really
well
marvel always excels when it comes to
action and the presentation and
production quality of the series
makes it something special this felt
movie level throughout
and to have almost 6 hours of something
this quality
is a testament to how much time and
effort that disney are pouring into
their shows
now one of the big questions that people
likely have is whether i prefer
this to one division or not what do you
mean you don't care well
i'm gonna tell you anyway i'm gonna say
something controversial
in that i actually preferred this over
one division though it didn't have as
many talking points throughout
i think a lot of my enjoyment with that
show came from my own speculation
and constant pointing at people saying
that they were mephisto
it made it far more engaging but when we
look at things after the fact
i feel that in terms of story and
substance that falcon in the winter
soldier
just beats it by a hair however if you
liked one division then that's cool
i can totally see things from your point
of view and i won't hold it against you
but get the hell out of here now as for
the fat wits
er falcon in the winter soldier i think
that knowing there was a big storyline
involving a virus that was cut
you can start to see the holes in
certain parts of the series
originally the series was going to have
a man-made virus which was unleashed by
the grc to kill
some of the refugees and this is what
nagel was tasked with curing by cauli
it also explains the vaccines that were
being stolen and loaded onto a plane
as well as mamadonia's death due to the
pandemic marvel decided to cut it
but because of this i think that it's
more difficult to relate to the flag
smashes plea
carly still didn't really give me that
sense of why so many people would follow
her
and lay down their lives in order to
enact her plans and at this point i'm
hoping that we do get an extended
version of the series
that shines her in a new light as for
joan walker
a lot of you got angry last time when i
said that he was probably the best
character
i was even called a typical white dude
which being brown-haired
plain faced youtuber i'm utterly
appalled at
what you mean there's about seven
thousand of us so fair enough
anyway i should rephrase that and say
that it's probably the best performance
and why russell has gone from someone
who's received death threats over his
portrayal
which though pretty crap also shows just
how good of a job he did as the new cap
but also yeah don't send death threats
to actors you're
[ __ ] now leading the series was of
course anthony mackie and sebastian stan
both have been doing these roles for
years now and it's at the point where
much in the same way that i'll always
think of robert downey jr when i picture
iron man
the pair will forever feel like the
perfect casting for their characters
it would be difficult to replace them
and though we've had things like
walker's ark and the flag smashers
thrust to the forefront of the series
the real story was sam accepting the
role that steve gave him
while spucky learned to forgive himself
for his past
it was really well laced throughout this
show and though often put on the back
burner
watching the pair uncover the truth
about the serum was a thrilling mystery
that i wanted to see them get to the
bottom of now as for zemo
daniel bruhl killed it and i can't wait
to see him more in the mcu
the first time i watched civil war i was
kind of mad on his understated
performance
and though over the years i've come to
accept that what he did was brilliant
this added way more dynamism to him the
dancing was
amazing and he was probably the funnest
character to be around in this series
similar to zemo sharon carter really got
a lot more of an expanded role
she was someone who in winter soldier in
civil war was just a bit meh
and i tell you down b m bargains which
is where i tend to buy my funko pops
they had piles and piles of civil war
sharon ones that were on sale for about
two pound
as they couldn't get rid of them however
this series made her someone very
important
i'm glad they've managed to do something
interesting with it now it's because of
reasons like that that i preferred it to
one division
but obviously let me know below if you
disagree overall though i think it was
an excellent show
and i can't wait to see these characters
back in the mcu now going forward we
have a lot lined up
and on june 11th we will be getting loki
this six episode series is set to follow
the version from endgame
as he goes through the multiverse
meeting alternate versions of himself
whilst he tries to save everything from
collapsing on july 11th we have the
release of black
widow finally what if is as of this
recording debuting over the summer
shang chi is in september along with
venom let there be carnage
the eternals is in november hawkeye is
in the latter part of the air as is
apparently ms marvel
and we close out with spider-man no way
home on december 17th
so it feels like we're just getting
started on what is one of the best times
to be a marvel fan ever
and i can't wait to see what's around
the corner we're going to be back with
miriam carey at some point to discuss
the series
so definitely keep an eye out for that
video next week obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on the episode
and the show as a whole as a thank you
for interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize through on the 30th
of april
in which we're giving away 3 copies of
zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the show
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
all the news on spiderman no way home
that we have so far which will be linked
on screen right now
alfred molina dropped a big interview
with variety last week
discussing how he's going to be
returning and we've just gone over all
the leaks on top of that
to give you a video that's worth
watching without the way thank you for
sticking through this
i've been poor and hopefully i'll see
you next time thank you for all the
support
have a great weekend you